สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่นะคะครับครู
นิกวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์ครับวัน
เสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 30 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกรกฎาคม
ครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25  65 ครับค่ะปี
ค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 20  22 ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงคะตอนนี้นะครับเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่
เนี่ยเวลา 8  8 ใช่ 52
นาทีเดี๋ยว
852 นโอเคนิ้ว
งงไม่รู้เอ๊จะชูกี่นิ้วดีชูนิ้วอะไรใช่
แล้วเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่กี่โมงแล้วครับ
เมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่เนี่ย
9  52 นนะคะตอนเช้าครับก็เร็วกว่าเมือง
คูนิ 1 ชมมอ่าโอเคโอเคเมื่อกี้ที่คุณงง
เกี่ยวกับนิ้วเพราะว่าคุณนิกอ่ะจะจะชิน
เวลายกแบบเหมือนกับว่า 1  2  3 แบบนี้แต่
บางครั้งเนี่ยพอเลข 2 อ่ะคุณนิก็จะชิงกับ
อันนี้ที่แบบสู้ๆใช่ๆมันแงงงว่าเอ๊ะจะ
ต้องอันนี้หรืออันนี้หรืออะไรบางคนอันนี้
ก็จะไม่รู้ว่า 2 หรอใช่ใช่ๆถ้ายกอันนี้แบ
เอ๊ะเลขอะไรอ่ะเออคนนี้ก็เลยคิดว่าเอ๊ะ
ต้องทำอะไรให้มันง่ายๆเพให้นักเรียนเข้า
ใจง่ายๆก็ก็เลยมือพันไปมกำลังคิดอยู่ว่า
จะยกเลขอะไรดีใช่ๆโอเคครับใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
แบบว่าบางทีแบบคือมือเนาะมันมันสามารถบอก
ได้อ่ะว่าเราอยากพูดอะไรหรือว่าอยากทำ
อะไรใช่มยิ่งถ้าแบบเราอยู่ในเมืองใน
กรุงเทพฯอย่างเงี้ยคือู้หญิงก็ไม่เคยเคย
ขึ้นรถเมล์ที่อเมริ
เนี่ย 1 ครั้งครับคือเรารู้สึกว่าที่
อเมริกาเราไม่ต้องใช้มือโบกรถเมล์อ่ะไม่
ต้องไม่ต้องใช่มยไม่ต้องเพราะว่าจริงๆ
แล้วที่เนี่ยเขาคก็เค้าก็จะบังคับเลยนะ
ว่าเหมือนอย่างเมืองของครูนิกเนี่ยถ้า
เป็นตอนกลางวันเนี่ยเขาจะบังคับเลยว่ารถ
เมล์ต้องจอดถูกป้าย
อืใช่คือเค้าก็จะสามารถคิดได้ว่าถ้า
สมมุติว่าไม่มีคนลงแล้วพอเขาไปใกล้ๆป้าย
รถเมล์แล้วมันไม่มีคนรอเาก็จะขับไปเลยอื
แต่คือเข้าจะต้องคิดแล้วว่าเค้าต้องจอด
ค่ะใช่ใช่เต้องที่เลนส์ของรถเมล์อยู่แล้ว
ออ๋อแล้วพอแบบเห็นข้างหน้าอ้อป้ายรถเมล์
มีคนเนี่ยยืนรออยู่ครับคือจะขึ้นสายของ
เา้าหรือว่าไม่ขึ้นเาก็ต้องจอดทุกป้ายอ๋อ
เพราะว่าแต่ถ้าที่ค่ะครับอ๋อเพราะว่าที่
ที่นี่ครับคือเหมือนกับเขามีตารางบอกไว้
แล้วว่าป้ายนี้รถเมล์จะมาเวลานี้ป้ายนี้
รถเมล์จะมาเวลานี้แล้วคนจะเช็คได้ว่าถ้า
ไม่ตรงเวลาเขาจะบอกเลยว่าสาย 2 นาทีสาย 3
นาทีคือต่างประเทศนะที่ครูนิกเจอเนี่ย
ขึ้นรถเมล์มันเชื่อได้มันไม่เหมือนที่ไทย
ที่โอเคมาเมื่อไหร่นะไม่รู้ไม่
รู้อมันก็เลยทำให้เขาต้องจอดทุกป้ายเพราะ
ว่ามันจะมีคนที่บางทีไม่ได้อยู่ที่ป้ายรถ
เมล์แบบยืนรอแบบไปซื้อของเหมือนรอในบ้าน
อะไรแบบเยครับก็มีอือืเพราะว่าพอดูเวลา
แล้วออเดี๋ยวรถเมล์จะมาแล้วเขาก็อาจจะ
เดินออกมาพอดีใช่เหมือนรถเมล์ต้องจอดแล้ว
ก็รอให้คนขึ้นบางประเทศนะใช่ถ้าเขามาเร็ว
กว่าแบบ 2 นาทีเขาต้องจอดรอจนถึงเวลาที่
เขาต้องออกจริงๆแล้วค่อยออกค่ะมันจะไม่
ได้ที่ไทยเลยที่ที่ไทยคือถ้าเกิดมองไกลๆ
เราไม่เห็นมีคนเนี่ยไม่เข้ามาเลยนะหรือ
ถ้าไม่โบกไม่เข้ามาเลยนะใช่เออถึงแม้ว่า
โบกแล้วก็ยังอยู่เลนนี้แหละใช่ไม่ใช่เลน
รถเมถนนเลยนะใช่คนที่ขึ้นก็
ต้องขึ้นรถเมล์ในประเทศไทยเนี่ยนะคะ
เหมือนไปวิ่งแข่งโอลิมปิกอ่ะค่ะนักเรียน
คุณต้องวิ่งเร็วนะคะเพราะว่าถึงแม้ว่ารถ
เมล์จะจอดแล้วคนจะเยอะแต่รถเมล์จะเปิด
ประตูนักเรียนจะมาเดินค่อยๆขึ้นไม่ได้ไม่
ได้นะคะคุณต้องแบบไม่รู้อ่ะจะตกรถหรือจะ
เป็นอะไรแต่ฉันต้องวิ่งไปขึ้นรถเมล์ให้
ได้ใช่เพราะว่าถ้ายิ่งไม่รีบเนี่ยคนขับรถ
ถ้ามองเห็นเราเเู้ออไม่ขึ้นของเราหรอก
เพราะไม่เห็นรีบใช่เออไม่เห็นวิ่งเลยเออ
ใช่อันนั้นก็เป็นเออมันก็เป็นเรื่องที่
ที่แปลกดีใช่ค่ะมันก็เป็นเรื่องที่แบบว่า
คนกรุงเทพฯโดยเฉพาะคนกรุงเทพฯนะถ้าเป็น
ต่างจังหวัดเนี่ยรถเมล์เนี่ยสบายๆนัก
เรียนอาจจะชอบมากกว่าก็ได้นะแต่ต่าง
จังหวัดรถเมล์ก็มีไม่เยอะนะไม่เยอะค่ะไม่
เยอะต้องแบบแต่รถเมล์จะเหมือนต่างประเทศ
ตรงที่ว่าว่าจะค่อนข้างตรงเวลาก็คือรู้
ได้เลยแล้วก็แบบแต่มันจะออกประมาณแบบ
ครึ่งชั่วโมงอย่างเงี้ยค่ะอย่างอย่าง
เมื่อก่อนเวลาครูหญิงอ่าจะอยู่กรุงเทพฯ
ใช่่มั้ยแต่ว่าครอบครัวอยู่ต่างจังหวัด
อย่างเงี้ยจะกลับบ้านแล้วก็จะนั่งรถเมล์
จากในเมืองอ่ะค่ะสมมุติรถทัวร์จาก
กรุงเทพฯมาถึงในเมืองชลบุรีแล้วจากชลบุรี
เนี่ยก็จะนั่งรถเมล์เข้าบ้านครับอ่าเขาก็
จะรู้เวลาว่าโอเคถ้าเราลงเนี่ยเดี๋ยวรถ
เมล์จะมากี่โมงคือคนคนแถวนั้นน่ะคนที่
เป็นคนที่เขานั่งรถเมล์บ่อยๆอ่ะค่ะเขาจะ
รู้เจะรู้ว่าอ่ะครึ่งชั่วโมงเนี่ยรถเมล์
อันไหนสายไหนเนี่ยจะมาอืแต่ก็ครับมันจะ
นานมากๆอจะนานใช่ก็ครูนิกเนี่ยจำได้ว่า
ตอนที่คุณนิกอยู่ที่ภูเก็ตเนี่ยทำงานที่
ภูเก็ตใช่มั้ยครับมันจะมีมันไม่ใช่ใช่รถ
เมล์หรอกเ้ามันเหมือนเป็นรถ 2 แถวใหญ่ๆ
อ่ะจริงๆเขาก็มีบอกว่าเป็นเวลาแต่ว่าไม่
เคยตรงเวลาเลยใช่เพราะคุณนิกจำได้ว่าเคย
ออกไปข้างนอกเวลาเดียวกัน 2 วันวันแรกมา
เร็ววันที่ 2 รอ 1 ชมงยังไม่มาเลยอือหู
ใช่รอ 1 ชมงยังไม่มาจนนิครูนิกแบบโทรหา
เพื่อนว่าเออไม่ไปแล้วนะขี้เกียจะรถเมล์
ไม่มาเออแล้วพ่งจะอาร้อนด้วยอ่ะตอนนั้น
น่ะอือืใช่ๆค่ะแล้วแบบมันเหนียวอ่ะนะทะเล
ด้วยใช่ๆก็เดี๋ยวนะแล้วมีอะไรเกี่ยวกับรถ
เมล์อีกก็แค่นั้นแล้วก็ส่วนใหญ่ถ้าใน
ภูเก็ตเาก็จะมีรถเมล์ที่เป็นรถเมล์แบบรถ
ปรับอากาศแต่อันนั้นก็จะเป็นจากสนามบิน
เข้ามาในเมืองอืใช่แต่ถ้ากรุงเทพฯเออแต่
ต่างจังหวัดไม่มีนะคะรถเมล์ที่เป็นปรับ
อากาศหรือว่ามีแอร์อ่ะรถเมล์เย็นๆเหมือน
ประเทศนักเรียนน่ะค่ะไม่มีเนาะต่าง
จังหวัดจะเป็นรถเมล์ที่เปิดนะคะแบบมีลมมี
ลมเข้ามาแต่ถ้ากรุงเทพฯกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยมีมี
ใช่แต่ก็เก่ามากนะอืมใช่ค่ะแอร์บางทีแบบ
แอร์แบบไม่ดีเปล่าอือือชั้นหายใจเข้าไป
นี่มีคาร์บอนมอนอกไซด์มีฝุ่นมีอะไรหรือ
เปล่าใช่เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยคครูนิกอาจะจริงๆ
ตอนนี้ก็เหมือนกันคครูนิกจะไม่ชอบนั่งรถ
ปรับอากาศคนไทยจะเรียกว่าปอเนาะอืรถเมล์
แอร์อ่ะค่ะรถเมล์เย็นบางคนก็เรียกว่ารถ
เมล์เย็นมันมีแอร์มันจะเย็นใช่มันเย็นแต่
คุณนิกรู้สึกว่าไม่ชอบเพราะว่าถ้าแอร์ไม่
เย็นเนี่ยมันไม่มีมันไม่มีอะไรที่มันจะมี
ลมเข้ามาได้อ่ะเพราะว่าถ้ารถแบบไม่มีแอร์
เนี่ยมันเปิดหน้าต่างได้แล้วคุณนิกเนี่ย
จะเป็นคนที่เหมือนกับปวดหัวง่ายเพราะว่า
ถ้ารถรถปอเนี่ยมันอแอร์มันทำงานไม่ดีแล้ว
มันอัมันไม่มีอากาศในรถมากพอเครุณนิกจะ
ปวดหัวละใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวหิเปิดให้ดูนะคะว่า
รถรถเม์แอร์เนี่ยมันมันเก่าขนาด
ไหนที่แบบว่านักเรียนคือจริงๆอ่ะมันก็
ใหม่แล้วนะในระดับนึงนะคะมันก็ใหม่อยู่นะ
แต่ว่ามันก็ไม่ใหม่อันนี้รึเปล่าจริงๆมัน
จะมีรถแบบคันใหม่เนี่ยมันจะเป็นสี
เหลืองเออถ้าสอันเนี้ยอันนี้คือแบบใหม่
แล้วครับใชนี่นะนี่นะนี่นะนี่อ่ะอันนี้
โอเคนะอูเอออันเนี้ยอันนี้แบบใหม่ที่ว่า
แถวบ้านคูนิกเนี่ยที่อยู่ชานเมืองอ่ะเป็น
เป็นแบบนี้ละอ๋อใช่ๆอันนี้จะเป็นรถเม์
แอร์นะคะแต่นี่คือแบบเก่าอ่ะอันนี้ไปสนาม
บินเนาะอันนี้คือรถเมแอร์แบบอันนี้ก็ยัง
โอเคนะอันนี้คนไทย
เรียกยูโรใช่มยรถใช่จริงๆคูณนิก็ยังไม่
รู้ว่าทำไมเรียกรถยูโรนะแต่ว่าเออค่ะเออ
แต่อันนั้นน่ะอันนั้นจะใหม่ขึ้นมาหน่อย
ถ้าแบบเก่าๆเลยเนี่ยมันจะเป็นสีน้ำเงิน
เข้มๆใช่แล้วก็จะมีอันนี้สีเหลืองสี
เหลืองก็ใหม่ใหม่ใหม่ใหม่โอเคใช้ได้นะคะ
อันเนี้ยคุณจำได้ว่าเพราะว่าบ้านคูนิ
เนี่ยมันจะมีคือถ้าเก่าสุดเนี่ยรถปรับ
อากาศจะเป็นแบบนี้เลยเอันนี้ใช่มั้ยครูนิ
อันเนี้ย
คือรถปรับอากาศแบบ
แรกใช่ค่ะแบบที่ 2 ก็คือยูโรแล้วพอแบบที่
3 ก็คือสีเหลืองอ่าโอเคสีเหลืองใช่แล้ว
อันล่าสุดเนี่ยก็คือสีน้ำเงินค่ะใช่อัน
เออนั่นแหละก็เป็นรถเมล์แอร์ใช่มแต่ถ้ารถ
เมล์ที่ไม่มีแอร์แเนี่ยนะคะคิดว่านัก
เรียนจะเคยเห็นก็คือเนี่ยสีแดงแบบ
เนี้ยมีหลายสีนะแต่ว่าก็จะมีสีแดงแบบนี้
อันนี้คือรสเมล์ร้อนนะคะอันนี้คือดีรจริง
ๆสภาพแบบเนี้ยคือดีแล้วใช่ดีแล้วแต่ว่า
ไม่มีพัดลมที่คนนั่งนะมีแค่คนขับลจริงๆ
มันมีพัดลมแต่ว่ามันพัดลมมันพังเออแต่คน
ขับเขาก็จะไปซื้อพัดลมมาเองเพราะว่าเขาอเ
ก็จะคิดว่าเออก็ร้อนน่ะอืแล้วเยใช่อืแต่
ว่ามันราคาไม่แพงนะครูหญิงก็ไม่รู้ว่าตอน
เนี้ยกี่บาทนะคะแต่ครูหญิงเคยขึ้นครั้ง
ล่าครั้งแบบล่าสุดครั้งสุดท้ายที่ขึ้นแต่
คือนานมากแล้วนะรถเมล์รถเมล์ร้อนนะคะรถ
เมล์สีแดงเนี่ยน่าจะ 7
บาทใช่ตอนนี้ยัง 7 บาทอยู่ใช่ๆเพราะคุณ
นิกจำได้ว่าคุณคุณนิขึ้นเมื่อปีที่แล้ว
ก่อนที่มา
อเมริกาใช่ราคา 7 บาทอืเพราะว่าช่วงหลัง
ก็คือขึ้น BTS ส่วนใหญ่อ่ะคะไปทำงานอย่าง
เงี้ยไม่ค่อยได้นั่งรถเมล์ก็เลยคนเปจะ
ขึ้นรถเมล์บางครั้งเวลาที่แบบไม่ได้รีบ
จริงๆเวลาที่เออมันคือไม่ไม่อยากกลับบ้าน
เร็วละแต่ก็อ่ะไม่รู้จะทำอะไรนั่งรถเมล์
ละกันจจริงๆนะเมื่อก่อนคุณหญิงเคยทำนะคุณ
ดิ๊กแบบว่าเราเรียนหนังสือเสร็จไงแล้วเรา
แบบเราก็ไม่อยากกลับบ้านน่ะคูหญิงก็นั่ง
รถเมล์นะนั่งรอบแบบเรารู้จักสายรถเมล์
อยู่แล้วไงเราก็จะนั่งไกลๆแล้วก็มาลงแล้ว
ก็นั่งรถเมล์ใหม่เหมือนนั่งรถเมล์เป็นวง
กลมกลับบ้านน่ะค่ะเออใช่เหมือนกันเหมือน
กันแล้วก็พูดถึงนั่งรถเมล์อันเนี้ยก็เค้า
เรียกว่าอะไรนะต่างประเทศกับที่เนี่ยมัน
ก็จะต่างกันนิดนึงที่ว่าที่ไทยเขาจะมี
กระเป๋ารถเมล์อ่ะใช่ๆๆเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงมีรูป
ให้ดูค่ะแต่กระเป๋ารถเมล์เนี่ยคือเป็นคน
นะไม่ใช่เป็นกระเป๋าที่ของรถเมล์คือเป็น
คนที่มีกระเป๋ารถเมล์อ่ะใช่ๆเนี่ยค่ะก็
คือผู้หญิงคนนี้ใช่เนาะแล้วเาก็จะมีเป็น
กระบอกอันเนี้ยค่ะนักเรียนเอ่าในเลแหละ
ที่ไว้เก็บเงินเนี่ยครับใช่อก็เดินและแกบ
ๆๆๆๆๆแล้วก็เอาละเก็บเงินถ้าเป็นปอเนี่ย
เค้าก็จะถามว่าไปไหนเพราะว่าเจะคิดตาม
ราคาตามเจะคิดตามระยะทางที่เราไปอืคือถ้า
ปอรถแอร์เนี่ยนะคะนั่งใกล้ก็จะถูกๆนั่งไป
ไกลๆก็จะแพงขึ้นแพงขึ้นแล้วแต่ว่าไกลแค่
ไหนใช่ๆเคนคนที่ทำงานแบบเครับในรถเมเราก็
จะจะเรียกว่ากระเป๋ารถเมล์อคือเคยบอกนัก
เรียนครั้งนึงแล้วเบอกว่าทำไมเรียก
กระเป๋าล่ะเพราะว่าเค้าเป็นคน
นะก็คุหิอยากจะรู้ด้วยว่ามันก็ไม่มี
กระเป๋านะอันนี้มันคือกระบอกอ่ะที่เขาค
ถืออยู่เก็บเงินมันคือกระบอกเก็บเงินเออ
แต่ก็เค้าเรียกว่ากระเป๋าคือคนนี้คิดว่า
มันอาจจะเป็นว่าเมื่อก่อนมั้งครับอาจจะมี
เป็นกระเป๋าที่ใส่พวกแบงค์หรือเปล่าอือาจ
จะก็ได้
แต่เราคือมันเป็นเออมันก็เป็นคนจริงๆเนาะ
เราเป็นคนไทยเราก็ไม่เคยสงสัยอะไรอ่ะเรา
ได้ยินมาตั้งแต่เด็กๆเออแล้วเขาก็จะรู้มี
ความรู้เยอะมากว่าเนี่ยอยากไปที่เนี่ย
ต้องลงป้ายไหนแล้วถ้าคือมันไม่ได้เป็น
เหมือนกับยกตัวอย่างถ้าคุณนี้บอกว่าอ๋อ
เนี่ยอยากไปจะไปวัด
มังกรต้องลงป้ายอะไรเบอกอ๋อๆเราไม่ได้จอด
ที่วัดมังกรนะแต่ว่าจอดใกล้ๆแล้วเดินไป
ได้เก็จะรู้เลยว่าต้องจอดตรงนี้หรือถ้า
เรานั่งรถแล้วเราจะหลับอ่ะคุณนิกทำบ่อย
คุณนิกก็บอกว่าเออบอกด้วยนะครับว่าถึง
ป้าย
แล้วเก็จำได้ใช่เ้าก็จำได้คืออันเนี้ยคุณ
นิก็ฟังแล้วคุณนิก็รู้สึกว่าเออมันก็แปลก
ดีในไทยเพราะว่าต่างประเทศเี่ไม่มี
กระเป๋ารถเมล์ไม่มีเลยใช่มั้ยคะใช่แล้ว
ทุกคนเนี่ยก็จะต้องรู้เองว่าลงป้ายอะไร
เพราะก็อาจจะถามคนขับรถได้คือรถเมล์ที่
ต่างประเทศเนี่ยเขาก็จะต้องจ่ายเงินกับ
ตอนขึ้นเลยอ่ะเขาจะแยกว่าตรงนี้ทางขึ้น
ตรงนี้ทางลงแล้วก็ตรงที่จ่ายเงินก็จะอยู่
กับคนขับรถค่ะใช่แล้วใช่ทุกคนเนี่ยจะต้อง
เหมือนกับรู้เองว่าจอะจะลงตรงไหนอืหรือ
ว่าแบบก็ก็คือถ้าถามคนขับได้ก็แค่บอกว่า
อ่ะสมมุติเราจะไปร้านนี้ร้าน A อ่าถนนถนน
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยก็ถามว่าเออรถเมล์เนี่ย
ผ่านตรงนี้มั้ยอันนี้คือเราถามกับคนขับ
ได้ถามได้เค้าก็บางคนก็รู้บางคนก็ไม่รู้
นะคือคนขับต่างประเทศเนี่ยเขาก็จะแค่คิด
ว่าเาจะจำชื่อถนนมากกว่า
อืเจะไม่รู้ว่าจุดตรงนั้นบางคนเนี่ยอาจจะ
รู้ถ้าเกิดว่าเขาเคยไปใช่อืคือเค้าแล้ว
เขาก็คิดว่ามันก็ไม่ใช่ก็คือคุณต้องรู้
เองว่าคุณจะลงตรงไหนสิ่งร้านที่คุณไป
เนี่ยอยู่ใกล้กับรถเมล์ป้ายตรงไหนอันนี้
คุณต้องรู้เองแต่ที่ไทยเนี่ยไม่เป็นไรเรา
ไม่รู้อืเรามีพี่กระเป๋ารถเมล์ใช่ๆที่นี่
และอีกอย่างคือเราอ่ะจะไปตะโกนบอกไม่ได้
นะว่าเออจอดด้วยแบบเนี้ยเราจะต้องกดเอง
แล้วถ้าไม่กดเบางทีเขาก็ขับผ่านไปก็ได้
ถ้ามันไม่มีคนแล้วมันไม่ใช่ความผิดเาอื
ใช่คือถ้าเป็นที่ต่างจังหวัดเนี่ยไม่มัน
จะไม่ได้มีป้ายรถเมล์ขนาดนั้นที่ต่าง
จังหวัดนะคะแบบรถอย่างรถเมล์แถวบ้านครู
หญิงอย่างเงี้ยที่ชลบุรีอ่ะก็อยากลงตรง
ไหนก็เหมือนครูนิกบอกว่าตะโกนบอกว่าว่า
จอดข้างหน้าด้วยออ่าพอรถจอดปุ๊บคนต่าง
จังหวัดถึงจะลุกขึ้นแล้วก็เดินๆๆเดินลง
จากรถคนที่อยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วแบบผู้หญิงมา
อยู่กรุงเทพฯแล้วจะรู้สึกแบบทำไมไม่ลุก
เลยคะอันนี้เราไงเพะพอเราอยู่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะ
เราจะรู้สึกว่าชีวิตมันเร็วอ่ะเราจะแบบ
คือเราจะแบบกดกริ่งแล้วเราจะยืนรอแล้วรถ
จอดแล้วเราลุบในกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยเราไม่ได้ลง
นะคะคนขับรถเมนี่ขับไปเลย
ไงพูดถึงอันนั้นน่ะคุณนิกอจะเคยเจอเป็นรถ
ตู้อ่ะรถตู้วันเนี้ยคือคดิก็ไม่เข้าใจนะ
รถตู้กับเหมือนแบบรถกระป๋องอ่ะคือบางที
เรากดกิ่งหรือเราบอกเขาว่าเราจะลงตรง
เนี้ยทุกคนในรถได้ยินแต่พอรถมันเต็มแล้ว
เรานั่งข้างหลังสุด
อ่ะพอเรานั่งข้างหลังสุดเนี่ยเราออกไม่
ได้เราก็แบบเออเอช่วยเขยิบหน่อยครับหรือ
ถ้ารู้ว่ามันเคนั่งขวางทางอ่ะก็ลงไปรอ
ข้างล่างหน่อยเราจะได้ออกแล้วเก็ขึ้นกลับ
มาได้เพราะว่าคนขับรถเขาก็รออยู่ดีอืๆๆ
ใช่รถตู้รถตู้เนี่ยมันเค้าไม่ได้รีบใช่ม
ไม่ได้รีบขนาด
แบบแบบอะไรนะแบบรถเมล์ขนาดนั้นน่ะค่ะคือ
เหมือนรถเมล์เค้ารีบเพราะว่าเาอจะต้องรีบ
ไปเอาคืออันนี้นะที่เคยได้ยินไม่รู้ว่า
มันจริงหรือเปล่าเขาบอกว่าที่รถเมล์เขา
รีบเนี่ยเพราะเขาอยากได้ลูกค้าเพราะเขา
ยิ่งได้ลูกค้าเยอะขึ้นรถเาเนี่ยเขาก็ได้
เงินเยอะอ่ะใช่ๆค่ะใช่แต่ว่าแได้เงินจาก
ค่าตัวรถเมล์ด้วยมั้งน่าจะคล้ายๆเป็น
เหมือนเปอร์เซ็นต์น่ะเปอร์เซ็นต์ว่าถ้า
แบบวันนี้ขับได้มีคนขึ้น 100 คนก็จะคูณไป
ว่าได้กี่เปอร์เซ็นต์ถ้าได้คนเยอะๆก็
เปอร์เซ็นต์เยอะเยอะๆเขาก็จะรีบมากๆคนไทย
ก็จะแบบวิ่งแบบวิ่งเก่งมากอ่ะค่ะคนที่
ขึ้นรถเมียใช่ๆก็เหมือนอย่างอะไรนะที่
เมื่อก่อนได้ยินเยอะๆเนี่ยที่กรุงเทพฯมัน
จะมีรถเมล์สายแตกใช่
แี้เออได้ยินเยอะมากเขารีบมากมากคุณคุณ
หญิงเคยขึ้น 1 ครั้งแบบคือมันผ่านหน้า
บ้านไงคะเคยขึ้น 1 ครั้งแล้วแบบไม่เอาอีก
แล้วเพว่าเราเป็นคนตัวเตี้ยไงเราแบบบางที
เราจับข้างบนน่ะไม่ถึงแล้วข้างล่างบางที
มันจับไม่ได้อ่ะแล้วรถขับแบบขับเหมือนรถ
ตัวเองคันเล็กๆอ่ะค่ะสาย 8 แต่เหมือนได้
ยินข่าวล่าสุดว่าไม่มีแล้วนะตอนนี้ไม่มี
ไม่มีรถเมล์เบอร์ 8 แล้วเไม่เอาแล้วยก
เลิกไปแล้วครับใช่โอ้เสียด Fast  and  the
Furious  in  Thailand นะคะเบอร์ 8 ใช
จริงๆจริงๆคือเร็วมากแบบครูนิเคยนั่งนะ
แต่ครูนิก็ชอบนะรู้สึกว่าเออสนุกใช่คือ
ผู้ชายแบบบางคนอาจจะโอเคด้วยความที่แบบ
ว่าคือถ้าบางคนที่ขึ้นรถเมล์เก่งๆอ่ะค่ะ
แล้วแบบอยู่ได้แล้วแบบพยายามรถขับเร็วแค่
ไหนเราก็อยู่ได้เนี่ยก็โอเคอ่ะค่ะแต่ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยโไม่ไหวคือมันรีบจริงๆขนาดว่า
เราอ่ะแค่เหยียบขึ้นบันไดไปอว่าโอเคเรา
ขึ้นน่ะไม่เไม่รอเลยนะเ้าก็แบบพอขึ้นปุ๊บ
โอเคพุ่งไปเลยนี้แบเ้ยออกเลยยังเยียบเบ
ขึ้นข้างบนไม่สุดเลยใช่ค่ะหรือแบถ้าเวลา
ลงเนี่ยเ้าก็จะบอกเลยนะแบบว่าเร็วๆ็ๆ็ๆ
เออเร็วๆเร็ว
ๆชิดในชิดในชิดในชิดในก็คือให้เราเดิน
เข้าไปข้างในอนักเรียนถ้านักเรียนนั่งรถ
เมล์จะได้ยินบ่อยๆมากชิดในชิดในชิดในก็
คือให้เราเดินเนี่ยเข้าไปข้างในเพื่อที่
คนที่ขึ้นมาใหม่เนี่ยจะได้ขึ้นมายืนได้
เบียดแบบเบียดจริงๆอ่ะปปลากระป๋องจริงๆ
เลยอ่ะใช่ค่ะก็คือใครฉีดน้ำหอมอะไรมาก็
คือได้กลิ่นนะค่ะกิผู้หญิงไม่ได้สระผมมา 3
วันก็คือได้กลิ่นเพราะว่ามันแบบอยู่ใกล้
กันมากๆนะคก็เป็นรถเมล์เนาะในประเทศไทยนะ
คะคือกรุงเทพฯเนี่ยที่เราเล่ามาอะไรเร็วๆ
ทั้งหมดเนี่ยคือกรุงเทพฯถ้าต่างจังหวัด
เนี่ยก็รถเมล์เาจะค่อนข้างช้าใช่นักเรียน
อาจจะรู้สึกไม่น่ากลัวเท่าแต่รถเก่ามากนะ
รถเมล์ต่างจังหวัดค่ะใช่เก่าจริงๆครับ
เก่ามากนะคะก็อันนี้ก็เราก็มาคุยให้ฟัง
เนาะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอ
หน้านะคะครับได้ไว้เจอในครั้งต่อไปนะครับ
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
สดี